UKRAINE WITH THE STORY.
SUZANNE?
>> Reporter: GOOD EVENING, PAM.
EXCLUSIVE TO CNN, A RUSSIAN
JUNIOR OFFICER WHO SPEAKS THAT
HE IS ANONYMOUS TO PROTECT THE
SAFETY AND THE IDENTITY SPEAKING
TO CNN SAYING HE WAS A PART OF
THE UNIT FEBRUARY 22nd THE TROOP
BUILD-UP ALONG THE BORDER WITH
UKRAINE AND THAT EVENING THAT
THEY WERE ORDER DS TO GIVE OVER
THE CELL PHONES AND LOST
COMMUNICATION WITH THE WORLD AND
ORDERED TO PAINT THE "Zs" ON THE
VEHICLES TO SYMBOLIZE THE
INVASION AND NO IDEA THAT THAT
WAS IN FACT THE MISSION.
THE FOLLOWING DAY IN CRIMEA.
HE DIDN'T KNOW THEY WERE GOING
TO MOVE FORWARD BUT ON FEBRUARY
24th HE SAYS, YES, HE WAS PART
OF THE LAUNCH OF THE WAR INSIDE
UKRAINE AND SAID MANY COMRADES
AND HIMSELF DID NOT UNDERSTAND
THE GOAL.
HE TELLS CNN, QUOTING HERE, WE
WERE NOT HAMMERED WITH A
UKRAINIAN NAZI RHETORIC.
MANY DID NOT UNDERSTAND WHAT
THIS WAS ALL FOR AND WHAT WE
WERE DOING HERE AND THE OFFICER
DESCRIBING THE DRIVE AND
ACTUALLY CONFRONTING LOCALS
SAYING HERE QUOTING, IN
GENESEEING THE LOCALS WE TENSED
UP.
SOME HID WEAPONS UBDS NOOERT THE
CLOTHES AND THEY FIRED.
HE TOLD CNN HE WOULD HIDE HIS
FACE FROM THE UKRAINIANS
EMBARRASSED OUT OF SHAME AND
SAFETY AND DIDN'T WANT THEM TO
SEE HIM ON THEIR LAND AND SAID
THE SECOND OR THIRD DAY WHEN
RUSSIAN FORCES CAME IRND FIRE
ATTACK AND AND HE WAS IN A STATE
OF AFTERSHOCK AND A COUPLE WEEKS
INTO THE WAR THINGS CHANGED FOR
HIM SAYING HE GOT A RADIO
RECEIVER AND GOT A LOOK INTO THE
NEWS HERE SAYING THAT'S HOW I
LEARNED THAT SHOPS ARE CLOSING
IN RUSSIA AND THE ECONOMY IS
COLLAPSING.
I FELT GUILTY AND MORE GUILTY
BECAUSE WE CAME TO UKRAINE.
AND THEN HE CONCLUDES, PAM, IN
THE END I GATHERED THE STRENGTH,
WENT TO WRITE A LETTER OF
RESIGNATION.
HE SAID THERE COULD BE A
CRIMINAL CASE.
THAT REJECTION IS BETRAYAL.
I STOOD MY GROUND.
PAM, HE WENT OFF.
HE IS NOW BA